>> Tucker: KANYE WEST, NOW YE,
WASN'T THE ONLY ONE WEARING A
"WHITE LIVES MATTER" SHIRT.
CANDACE OWENS WAS SITTING RIGHT
NEXT TO HIM.
SO WE ASKED WEST WHAT THAT WHOLE
THING WAS LIKE IN HIS WE TOLD
US.
>> THE MORE I LEAN INTO GOD AND
WORK FOR GOD, THE MORE WINS GOD
IS GOD OF THE STONE ARE TEAM.
ON'S TEAM.
AND FOR ME TO JUST GO OUT AND
STAYED AN OBVIOUS AND EMPATHETIC
STATEMENT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
MOST LIBERAL CENTURY, THAT WAS
LIKE TIANANMEN SQUARE.
WITH CANDACE OWENS.
AND WE BOTH WORE THE SHIRT AT
THE SAME TIME.
YOU KNOW, WE'VE GOT SOME
SOLDIERS OUT HERE.
PEOPLE SAY THEY'RE WILLING TO
DIE FOR HER BUT WE LIVE FOR IT.
WE LIVING FOR THE BATTLE READ
WHAT'S THE BATTLE FOR?
LIFE ITSELF.
OUR CHILDREN.
>> Tucker: LIKE TIANANMEN
SQUARE.
STAYING THERE IN FRONT OF THE
TANK WHICH IS INTERNATIONAL
MEDIA.
CANDACE OWENS IS THE HOST OF THE
PODCAST CAN THIS AND THANKS SO
MUCH FOR COMING ON.
WHAT DID YOU DO THAT?
YOU DID IT TOGETHER.
AND WHAT YOU THINK OF THE
RESPONSE?
WHY CAN'T YOU DO THAT?
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY IT'S ONE
OF THE ONLY WEEKS I MISS DOING A
SHOW, THE ONLY REASON I WOULD
MISS DOING A SHOW TUCKER IS
BECAUSE I KNEW THERE WAS A
CULTURAL MOMENT THAT WOULD BE SO
SIGNIFICANT AS THIS WAS.
I DID BECAUSE KANYE CALLED ME
AND HE SAID THAT HE NEEDED ME TO
BE THERE AT THE SHOW, HE NEEDED
ME TO TO BE A PART OF THE SHOW.
WHEN HE TOLD ME WHAT HE HAD IN
MIND, WEARING THESE T-SHIRTS, HE
TOLD ME THE DAY OF, I INSTANTLY
UNDERSTOOD WHO IS TRYING TO DO
AND WHAT THE ARTISTIC EXPRESSION
WAS.
IT OFFERED A STUNNING COMMENTARY
ON THE HYPOCRISY OF THE SOCIETY
SOCIETY WE LIVE IN.
PREVIOUS ROUTABLE BLACK LIVES
MATTER WAS NOT AN EXCLUSIONARY
PHRASE.
WE WERE TOLD THAT IT'S JUST WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING, THEY'RE NOT
TRYING TO LEAVE WHITE PEOPLE
OUT.
IT'S A MOMENT BLACK AMERICANS
NEEDED TO HAVE THEIR MOMENT.
ASIANS ARE DOING BETTER THAN
WHITE AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY
AND THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO GET
CREDIT CARDS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE
AND YET DESPITE ALL OF THAT IT
WAS OKAY THAT ASIAN LIVES
MATTER.
WE PUT ON A T-SHIRT TO ACTUALLY
DO SOMETHING THAT WAS SO
INCLUSIVE, ACTUALLY, WHITE
AMERICANS ARE ALLOWED TO BE PART
OF THIS TOO.
BECAUSE ALL LABS MATTER.
BUT NO LAPSE OF MATTER.
BLACK LIES HAVE SUFFERED BECAUSE
OF BLACK LIVES MATTER.
BUSINESSES ARE MOVING OUT OF
INNER-CITY COMMUNITIES.
ASSUMING THAT BLACK AMERICANS
WERE STUPID AND EMOTIONAL AND
WITH GLUTEN RIOT THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES TO FULFILL A FALSE
NARRATIVE ABOUT POLICING, WHITE
SUPREMACISTS WERE BEHIND THAT.
WE GOT TO SAY ALL OF THAT WITH
ONE T-SHIRT.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE
TRIGGERED BY A SHIRT LIKE THAT,
NO ONE WHO IS EVER MAD ABOUT IT
EVER ASKED WHY?
IF IT SAID MALAYSIAN LIVES
MATTER OR ANYBODY, A NORMAL
PERSON WOULD SAY, OF COURSE, ALL
LIVES MATTER.
BUT WHY DOES IT MAKE THEM SO
MAD?
>> BECAUSE THERE'S ACTUALLY IN
THIS COUNTRY THERE'S A HATRED
TOWARD WHITE PEOPLE AND IT'S
UNDENIABLE.
THE WORST THING YOU COULD BE IN
THIS COUNTRY FAR FROM WHAT
THEY'RE TELLING YOU, A BLACK
CHILD IN THE WOMB IS AN
DANGEROUS AND THEN A WHITE
STRAIGHT MALE IS DANGEROUS, YOU
NEED TO MAKE YOURSELF PROBLEM
THE TIES, THAT YOUR SUFFERING,
THAT YOUR TRANS, THAT YOU'RE,
THAT YOUR THE PRODUCT OF ABUSE.
YOU CANNOT USE THE TERM WHITE
LIVES MATTER BECAUSE THEY SAY IT
INSPIRES HATRED.
IN FACT, BANNING "WHITE LIVES
MATTER" IS WHAT CAUSES HATRED.
AFTER WEARING THE SHIRT GETTING
BACK HERE, I WENT TO A
FARMERS' MARKET, AND I HAD WHITE
PEOPLE COMING UP WITH TEARS IN
THEIR EYES, SAYING, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANKS FOR ALLOWING US TO HAVE
OUR VOICES BACK.
THEY'VE BEEN SIDELINED, TOLD
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO BE
AMERICAN BECAUSE IT'S A A
VICIOUS NARRATIVE AROUND BECAUSE
SOMEHOW BLACK AMERICANS ARE
SUFFERING FROM POLICING AND
WHITE LIVES DON'T MATTER.
BUT CONNIE WAS CORRECT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW WHY
PEOPLE PUT UP WITH IT.
I CAN'T IMAGINE ANY GROUP THAT
SHOULD PUT UP WITH THI